okay before I do anything else today I
want to take a second to thank all of
you who have supported the Rubin Report
since we went independent back in June
that goes for all of you who watch
engage with and share our videos but
especially for those of you who have
donated to The Rubin Report via
Patreon or Paypal. Almost 3,000 of you
can proudly consider yourselves
producers of this show. You not only give
us the monthly budget to continue The
Rubin Report every week but you also
keep the show free for everybody else.
This show based on big ideas and honest
conversations, talking to people who I
both agree with and disagree with, is
really just at the beginning of what we
can do as our own production company.
We've got some big plans and i'll
explain those in just a second.
The way we produce The Rubin Report
right now is with nothing between me and
you, the audience. There's no producer
screaming in my ear telling me what to
say and there's no corporate Overlord
telling me what to do.
I truly wouldn't trade this intellectual
freedom for a million-dollar contract on
CNN.
So with this in mind we've decided to
take the final step into becoming fully,
truly independent. Over the past few
weeks our production company took out a
major loan to build a home studio. Life's
about taking risks - we've already taken a
couple of them and we figured why not
take one more? Once we fully build this
studio out which is happening as we
speak,
we'll be able to shoot whenever we want,
for however long we want. This will give
The Rubin Report incredible flexibility
not only to shoot more shows every week
but also to do more collaborations with
people you know and love, host real
debates on polarizing topics, and come up
with new ideas for segments on the fly.
Ultimately the best way to share these
ideas of free speech and honest
conversation is for me to be beholden
to nobody but you, the fans. That's really
the beauty of what's going on here. You
guys have helped us grow and share this
message across the globe.
I genuinely love connecting with our
Patrons every month via our private
Google Hangouts, the patreon group chat,
our exclusive live streams, and more.
Beyond that i'm amazed and awed how many
of you guys are connecting with each
other and starting your own blogs or
YouTube channels or just bringing these
conversations to your dinner table. So
for those of you who are in Patrons yet
this is your chance to become a producer
of The Rubin Report and help us hit our
next goals.
To show we're serious about growing the show,
and fast, we'll be starting to do two
interviews per week beginning next week.
Yep, double the content immediately. Help us
get to our next goals on Patreon and the
show will grow as much as you want it to.
Everything we're doing at The Rubin
Report is because you've enabled us to
continue to do it. I hate to sound corny
but you make me a better man. Speaking of
better people my producer David and my
head of production Amiria are seriously
the best team in the business.
These are truly the hardest-working
people in the biz and more importantly
they never yell at me for tweeting too
much. Together we can do this show for a
year for roughly the same cost as one
episode of a cable news show.
We weren't expecting to make this move
so quickly but the timing really is
perfect. The media landscape is changing
so fast and our true independence will
be the key to growing not only the show,
but a real political movement. The
election is absolute proof that we need
to tackle difficult topics and
controversial ideas honestly. Most people
don't want the endless fighting we've
become accustomed to, but we're the ones
who have to fight to be heard the most.
This is my call to action to all of you,
not only can you help keep this message
alive but you can help grow it with no
outside influence and with nothing
between us.
Alright so if you've heard me and you
feel what I feel, jump over to
patreon.com/rubinreport or
rubinreport.com/donate and check out our
next goals and some of the plans we have
to grow The Rubin Report. And if you
don't have the means right now than I
hope you'll just keep watching and
sharing our videos. In short, the future
of the human civilization is up to you. I
hope you'll join us for this wild ride.